What's one interview question you ask every prospective employee?
I like to see how people think.
So, very often I ask questions
that are inferential
so they are not really looking into the knowledge
because I know that someone may have done the research
and someone may have not done the research.
And although I can appreciate the enthusiasm
and the desire that someone may show,
so I evaluate that,
I often ask questions that
are questions like,
"How many golf balls do you have
in the United States?"
And I am not looking for an answer
that tells me the exact number,
but I want to know how they think.
And again, this goes to the idea
that we are moving to a world
where people don't care so much
about the product in itself.
Products are becoming more and more commodities.
But people care about our ability
to challenge their way of thinking.
They enjoy the fact that we are bringing
something to a conversation.
So, you want at the end of a meeting
with a C-level person
who has given you a half an hour, one hour of their time,
to make them feel like they didn't waste
that hour with you,
but I don't want to say that they learned something,
but they saw things with a different perspective.
So, I like young people
who can really put these thoughts together
and say, "Yes, I don't know the answer to that,
but this is how I get to an answer."
And I think very often that gives me a lot of ideas
whether or not that person will be able to master
some more sophisticated and complex thoughts and ideas
that we will feed them,
but they would be,
they would need to be able to accept those ideas
and then elaborate their own way of thinking
around those ideas.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.